on va donner dans un instant les
chiffres de complément d'enquête mais
euh juste
avant on avait les réactions de Hugo
manos oui moi j'ai trouvé ça un peu
grotesque et et bas de planché euh je me
suis pas du tout reconnu dans le
portrait qu'on faisait des des
chroniqueurs moi je suis quand même là
depuis 2 ans même si je suis pas souvent
là et et en fait j'ai eu l'impression de
découvrir une émission que je ne connais
pas de découvrir un animateur que je ne
connais pas un homme que je ne connais
pas euh donc moi ça me pose problème
parce que tu disais que c'était bien que
qu' passe tout un reportage sur Cyril
oui mais il faut que ça soit juste et là
en l'occurrence c'est totalement
injuste je trouve ça moi je trouve que
pour moi c'est c'est le le la réunion de
de personnes qui qui détestent Cyril et
qui veulent le descendre donc en le
regardant bien évidemment il des
séquences qui m'ont fait sourire mais au
fond quand je prenais du recul et quand
on prenait du recul avec Laurent on se
disait mais mais quelle injustice et et
quelle manque
d'objectivité pour pour le service
public c'est c'est quand même dramatique
je trouve donc donc oui ça moi moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai j'ai pas aimé moi j'ai pas
aimé regarder ça et je me suis ditf même
quand je regarde Twitter d'ailleurs
quand je regarde Twitter et que je vois
toutes les fake news les les les les les
comme tu disais tout à l'heure là tous
ces trucs de propagande soit disant ce
qui se passe ici mais attendez mais moi
je suis là je suis là je n'ai jamais vu
ça moi personne ne me fait me fait
parler quand je dis quelque chose
parfois personne est d'accord tout le
monde va me huer mais c'est pas grave je
dis ce que je pense et quand on part il
y a pas de problème je me dis dis pas
est-ce que je vais est-ce qu'on va
m'engueuler mais jamais on a essayé de
dicter ce que je pouvais dire et ce que
je pouvais penser on dirait pas autant
de conneries oui
comment on dirait pas autant de
conneries il y aurait pas il y aurait
pas autant d'avis différents aour autour
de la table donc on peut pas rigoler
avec ces chosesl on pe ça t'a énervé toi
t'neréouis à la fin je me suis dit mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc là et
puis le le final avec avec un échange
lunaire qui a aucune élévation
intellectuelle c'est là on parle un peu
comme attend c'est France de c'est c'est
complément d'enquête c'est PP le côté
sociétal ce que ça représente
aujourd'hui pour
la ce qui m'a manqué je dis c'est là où
il faut c'est incroyable moi moi si
j'avais fait l'émission j'aurais
j'aurais fait un montage moi qui souffre
dans le cul d'un chien et moi qui parle
après avec Gérald darin
en face à Baba ça c'était marrant pour
montrer voyez ou pas mais c'est ça qui
est marrant ça ça on aura rigolé ça
c'est vrai que le montage la prochaine
fois il me demande voilà moi je leur
facture c'est rien du tout voilà c'est
grave parce que un moment il y a eu
quand même un long moment où il y a eu
une hypothétique homophobie quiiendrait
de ta part non mais c'est sûr on va on
va y revenir
làdus parce que ça c'était un gars c'est
un gars qui a dit un autre gars qui a
dit un gars qui a dit un autre gars qui
a dit un gars que un gars avait dit ça
il a aussi l'allusion au chroniqueur gay
qu'on humilie plus que les autres
pourquoi parce qu'il est gay enfin c'est
des accusations qui sont graves donc
faut qu'on revienne dus non mais je te
c'est voilà c'est comme si on disait on
une humilie Daniel parce qu'elle est un
peu plus âgée que nous non et pu même il
y avait un fond de sexisme aussi c'est
alors on parler tout à l'heure n allons
parler tout à l'heure les chéri quand on
parler des des chroniqueurs téléguidé
Raymon moi je fais partie des gens qui
sont réveillés avec une gueule de bois
parce qu'on a attendu jusqu'à 1h du
matin on est parti au taf le matin on s
on est éclaté on est fatigué pour voir
quoi pour voir des chroniqueurs qu'on
connaît pas parce qu'on j'aurais voulu
voir des anciens chroniqueurs qui
étaient là mais qui aurait parlé mais
apparemment on parler de quoi parce
qu'il y a rien à dire on a vu des des
des gens c'est des pharmaciens une une
une chroniqueuse je la connais même pas
tout ça tout ça pour ça tout et de
l'autre côté je rejoins Valérie il y a
les gens qui ont regardé pour savoir ce
qui allait se passer de trash si tu
sortais en soirée s'il y avait de la
drogue s'il y avait de l'alcool si
Anouna il faisait la fête sur les Champs
Élysée à 1h du matin avec une bécane il
il y a pas donc les gens d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs Laurent m'a dit que j'étais
un peu chiant la semaine très chiant
très chiant donc ces gensl ont ét par P
reportage
oui non j'ai dit il auraient dû en
parler pendant le reportage vrai donc
ces gens-l ont été déçus et les gens qui
te connaissent si tu regardes tes PMP
tous les soirs tu en apprends plus sur
toi que sur le complément d'enquête
parce qu'ils ont parlé d'un bateau mais
si tu regardes t p tous les soirs Jean-M
fait des Vanes Valérie fait des Vanes on
on en apprend plus prior priorité on
dira qu' a ma mère qui réagit à ce que
tu as dit qui dit mais Hugo ils ne
réussiront jamais à descendre mon fils
c'est un monstre
jalousie bravo c'est exactement ça ça
ça'appud juste un truc qui est pas vrai
c'est non mais c'est c'est relou même
les anciens si si si des des anciens des
anciens gars qu' on travaillé là à
visage découvert d'anonyme d'anonyme de
mon frère qui m'a dit que mon père une
fois il est monté dans un taxi et il lui
a dit que les mec arrêtez arrêtez les
conneries 2 minutes arrêtez donc c'était
mais c'est bien pour France 2 ça fait 3
millions c'est TR bien pour
France matin je dire c'était ma victoire
vérité parce que ça se serait
planté voilà et moi je veux dire et ça
m'a donné ça m'a donné une idée ça m'a
donné une idée ils m'ont ils m'ont donné
une
idé ça déç beaucoup de gens je pense que
je vais faire un truc très prochain
qui va arriver vous allez voir mais ça
m'a donné une
idée dans dans l'air du temps là dans ce
qui se passe voilà le chiffre de ce
matin de 3 million m'a donné m'a donné
une idée jaces card on a eu votre avis
alors non non je me suis pas encore
exprimé comme je comme je
dire la minute
Cardo non mais je peux pas dire que des
choses négatives donc d'abord d'abord je
trouve sur la forme c'est très très bien
produit je trouvais que c'était vraiment
très beau en terme de de graphisme de
montage et il direou c'est moi qui avais
mis en place les équipes pas non non pas
du tout pas du tout Rigo moi je l'ai pas
trouvé bien produit ouais pardon je
trouve que sur le montage c'est très
très bien produit voilà l'écriture et
franchement c'est c'est pas une copie
machin donc je dis je dis je dis ça
parce que je le pense vraiment je trouve
que l'écriture elle est assez fine donc
j'ai trouvé ça bien écrit en revanche
sur le fond je trouve que il y a cinq
raisons qui me font penser que c'est
totalement raté
la première c'est qu'il y a pas de scoop
on apprend rien ouais ce qui est quand
même la base lorsque tu fais une enquête
exactement on parle d'investigation de
reportage de cés ont dit portrait après
ils ont ché plusquêtera alors justement
alors à propos alors à proposrait à
propos du portrait pour moi il y a deux
choses qui manquent fondamentalement
mais vraiment là qui m'ont manqué quand
je regardais le le doc la première c'est
que lorsqu'on a fait les portraits de
Dupont Moretti de Carlos g de n'importe
qui il y a toujours une dimension
psychologique où on essaie de savoir un
petit peu euh ce qu'il y a dans la tête
de la personne et ça tu le fais je sais
pas s'il y a eu des questions làdessus
mais non mais mais si mais ça c'est
quelque chose que tu peux faire à la
fois avec des proches mais aussi tout
tout simplement avec avec des psis avec
des gens qui savent analyser et je
trouve que c'est toujours passionnant
lorsqu'on raconte quelqu'un qui est
mystérieux qui suscite beaucoup de
fantasmes d'avoir un moment d'analyse où
on fait monter un peu la saauce sur
voilà il est comme ça ça ça explique un
ego ça ça explique ceci ça ça explique
cela et plein de choses comme ça et donc
ça cette dimension là elle m'a manqué
énormément le deuxième point c'est que
je sais pas comment journalistiquement
on peut faire un portrait sans jamais
raconter ton enfance ça c'est
surréaliste non attends excuse-moi mais
moi je serais parti en Tunisie il a dit
qu'il avait parlé 3h on l' l' vu minut
moi cyil je je là en direct je dis je ne
connais pas en fait ton enfance je la
connais pas donc je serais parti en
Tunisie j'aurais essayé de retrouver des
gens j'aurais raconté cette histoire
j'aurais
bien mais oui mais franchement je suis
curieux de la connaître cette histoire
là tu parles souvent des des clubs et
cetera je trouve que il y a peut-être
des images qui correspondent à ce
moment-là tout ça n'a pas été raconté
des anciens collègues des gens qui t'ont
vu des des des des des clients
mêmeimateur je suis de le donuc même ce
que je fais comme métier C là je suis en
train de leur donner le menu du chapitre
2 en fait parce que tout ça on l'a pas
vu l de quoi faire un chapitre 2 sur ce
pointl donc ça c'est le deuxème point
ensuite tu racontes toi-même ta
fascination pour des gens ici même
parfois un peu obscur moi je connais pas
vous dites ouais j'ai des potes ils
sortent parfois de prison ils ont fait
des ça c'est pas du tout apparent dans
le doc alors que ce soit un fantasme pas
un fantasme que ce soit de mecs 10
mec même à la fin je vais vous dire même
à la fin ils auraient dû aller vers ça
parce que on on va parler de B tout à
l'heure à la fin il lui dit est-ce que
vous avez peur ti il dit non
mais entourage
og en fait en fait tu aurais dû aller
voir ces garsl c'est vrai je suis
d'accord avec toi donc ça c'est le là et
ensuite je suis complètement d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit Géraldine tout à
l'heure et je trouve que ça mais alors
vraiment c'est un des trucs qui m'a qui
m'énerve le plus avec france télé et je
l'ai vécu ça c'est pas que complément
c'est vraiment le service public je l'ai
ressenti tout le temps sur plein
d'occasions c'est cette espèce de mépris
de public et on va vous raconter quel
est ce public là et C t les poubelles et
donc ces gens qui sont des neux et des
gens qui viennent et qui font 2 heur de
voyage et il y a un mépris total pour ça
et ça c'est un une des choses qui me qui
me révulse le plus ça se ressent dans le
début c'est pour ça que j'ai tweeté sur
le TT sur le le micro trottoir au tout
début j'ai réfléchi un truc tout à
l'heure combien ça ferit un complément
d'enquête sur Nag est-ce que ça
marcherait
Laur ch pourquoi ils font pas un
complémentqute je vous dire la vérité
entre nous et je dis pas ça pour me la
péter ou quoi N tu fais un complément
d'enquête sur Nagi ça fait 700000 s'
fè il va l non mais je l'aime bien Nagi
mais Bonon s'
fout F mais
franchement mais c'est ça qui qui me r
fout c'est que il y avait tellement de
gens ou qui me déteste qui qui m'adore
et c'est ça qui est fou c'est que 3
millions je dire sils avaient fait ça la
question que j'ai envie de poser
complément d'enquête Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que ça fait plus que 3 millions
ah je pense pas non non je pense pas non
mais complément d'enquête sur Nag
honnêtement ça fait ENF Macron ça fait
un gros score je pense dans ouais un
million et
demi les meurs comprend pas en fait donc
c'est tout le buz autour tu fais un
complément sur Macron tuas ça veut dire
qu'il y a une promesse donc s'il y a une
promesse faut qu'il y a quelque chose au
bout s'il y a rien ça fait je parle de
dis voil m
in
inér dans les briefs que j'avais moi
avec l'équipe systématiquement lorsque
on lançait quelque chose il y avait
toujours ok la promesse elle est là mais
est-ce qu'on est sûr de pouvoir chercher
quelque chose est-ce qu'on peut tu
t'agit éta sûr parce qu'il y avait plein
de rumeurs donc toi ça avait jamais été
fait il y avait beaucoup de rumeurs ils
étaient certains de l'UD après moi je
trouve que Tristan après qu'on l'aime
qu'on l'aime pas il a réussi son coup
les gars il a fait 3 millions les gars
terminé il a fait 3 millions merci au
revoir tu lui dit moi je suis le gars de
France Télé tu l'enquête elle t'a plus
ou pas tu as fait 3 millions de
tlpectateurs merci tu as fait le record
historique tu as fait 52 sur les 15 34
écoute-moi bien il va passer un bon
weekend hein il va pouvoir s'acheter des
il est tranquille c'est sûr non non mais
c'est Sr une t de avec avec le vrai
sommaire de Jacques je pense qu'ils font
beaucoupouais mais c'est
bon j'adore moi non mais franchement et
dernière petite chose parce que voilà je
suis croqué à la fin je trouve ça
mesquin et pas gentil s'ils ont quelque
chose à dire sur moi bah qu'ils le
disent mais euh vouloir juste prendre
l'image de moi en Johnny pour me
ridiculiser en disant notre ancien
collègue et en plus ne le croyez pas
parce que il nous promet queil va
protéger ses sources je le dis là j'ai
jamais trahi personne en matière de
source journalistiquement tous les gens
qui témoignent pour moi qu'on me s le
truc quoi j'ai jamais trahi personne et
ça franchement je l'ai ressenti je le
dis à Virginie à Castex à Plagnard c'est
vraiment méchant c'est méchant juste JAC
moi je voudrais juste dire un truc
là-dessus c'est là où il se trompe
complètement on peut mettre une perruque
faire Johnny faire des conneries rigoler
être un très bon journaliste voilà
exactement ça je vous dis ça ve dire que
il y a que des gars quand tu es
journaliste tu dois faire que des trucs
sérieux il peut très bien faire Johnny
faire une per au contraire c'est là
c'est là sa force et c'est là qu' va
faire qu'il va aller beaucoup plus haut
que vous je vous le dis bah je vous le
dis je dis bah là c'est vraiment ça
c'est nul à chier voilà Patrick
Sébastien que j'adore vous le savez
Patrick Sébastien il est aussi tant
capable de mettre une perruque faire le
con que de parler de tous les sujets et
demain tu demain tu fais une émission de
débat avec Patrick Sébastien je peux
dire qu' il est incroyable voilà donc ça
veut rien dire c'est n'importe quoi
voilà Paul bah moi en fait quand j'ai
regardé je m'attendais à ce que tu sois
carrément tueur en série au final on
apprend que tu t'as acheté un et que tu
as soufflé dans le cul d'un chien je ve
dire ça arrive tu vois donc non mais
c'est vrai j'étais grave déçu en plus
pareil
sur les gens dehors dans le dans le sur
le trottoir j'avis l'impression que ça
allit décrédibilisé mon père il regarde
tes PMP c'est pas un débile et là on a
pris les téléspect téléspectateurs pour
des cons